tell me what this emotion tell me about
these tears
accomplishing something that I've been
dreaming of you know
life hearing that that sentence from
Adam Silver you know I've dreamed of it
so so much that you know
I gotta cry man
Eve Oscar Victor's siblings there were
tears for you guys what has it been like
watching your brother in this Pursuit
that's amazing we're all so proud we're
very happy for you we are happy for the
family for the friends for everything
for the basketball that's so amazing
yeah yeah I knew that was I was gonna
material uh gonna have tears because
every time I thought about this sentence
like with the first pick and everything
I got this little tears in my eyes and I
knew that I wasn't gonna let let them in
my eyes yeah that's crazy
[Music]
Victor I do have to ask you though you
have been labeled generational Talent so
many people are thrilled about your
potential in the NBA and you have said
that you don't feel pressure because
it's just basketball how do you begin to
leave your mark on this league
you know I'm a I don't know you know
it's it's a tough League it's tough to
win to win this league you know many
players have tried to win three for
years for decades and haven't made it so
my goal is I'm gonna try and learn as
quick as possible because I want to win
that ring well you are going to a
storied organization in the San Antonio
Spurs
speaking of the Spurs your teammate
Jeremy Sohan is here to welcome you
for so long
Jeremy obviously a current player with
this version